[Musique]
encore à coup ça y est on est sur un
chemin communal s'est interdit de
barrières chemin communal il doit rester
libre de la circulation de ce soit à
pied à cheval ou à vélo devoir passer et
là bas qu'est ce qui se passe on sait
pas ma façon on voit ça couramment 1 sur
cette propriété
voilà hélas la bombe on va franchir
quand même on va aller voir plus loin
mais en se méfiant qui n'est pas une
chasse parce qu'on est des fois prendre
une balle puisque de la cm ça ils
pensent qu'ils ont droit de thierry suc
semaine comme unis tirent ils servent
les chemins de communes comme à l'est de
tir et ça c'est inadmissible
il y a vingt ans qu'il se bat pour la
libre circulation du gibier marie et
raymond louis sont solognot et chasseurs
mais le coeur de leur combat ce sont les
grillages à la voyez donc à gauche là
une clôture clôture de chez monsieur bic
là nous sommes sur le chemin communal et
de l'autre côté du chemin à nouveau une
clôture
donc ça piège les animaux y sont ils
sont vraiment piégée
la sologne cent mille kilomètres carrés
de forêt sur trois départements le
loir-et-cher le loiret et le cher le
plus prestigieux territoire de chasse
français aujourd'hui au centre d'une
vaste polémique
plus de 3500 kilomètres de grillages
kadri désormais la région et le
phénomène ne cesse de s'amplifier
ce matin réunion de guerre à paris il y
à la françois bonneau le président de la
région centre val de loire
guillaume pelletier député du
loir-et-cher nicolas vanier le cinéaste
thierry costes le conseiller des manuels
macron hubert louis vuitton vice
président de la fédération des chasseurs
les représentants des services de l'état
et des associations et tout ce beau
monde n'est pas vraiment sur la même
longueur d'onde
on n'a pas attendu ton film pour parler
des grillages des grillages fait plus de
vingt ans trente ans qu'on en parle en
sologne et autres dans les autres
départements aussi parce que en gros
c'est quoi ces dix personnes à qui nous
en met plein dans l'absolu c'est tout
vous savez qui on va attaquer oui vous
êtes prêts à attaquer toutes ces grandes
personnes
ces grandes personnes une trentaine de
gros propriétaires souvent des patrons
du cac 40 qui concentre tous les griefs
j'ai un deuxième chemin rural à moins
d'un kilomètre de là où ce propriétaire
a posé une fille canadienne sur une
commune ou lyrique à la diète sont
interdits depuis 2007
on l'a fait retirer cnv canadienne a été
remplacé par un portail automatique à
l'extérieur de sa propriétaire des
cellules automatisé à 50 cm de haut ce
qui fait qu'un cochon peut l'ouvrir à
l'intérieur c'est à dire chez lui
les cellules souches un plus d'un mètre
de hauteur et donc c'est pas le drapage
idée ça à l'issue de la réunion
un courrier est adressé à emmanuel
macron pour faire évoluer la loi et les
réglementations
vaste programme tout le monde
aujourd'hui est d'accord sur le fait
qu'il y a un problème extrêmement grave
qui est lié au cloisonnement des
territoires à l'engraissement
donc il faut qu'on rentre aujourd'hui
dans les solutions à proposer envisagée
je veux une image positive pour la
sologne et nul n'a intérêt à vivre sur
un territoire qui serait un territoire
retranché ça n'est pas ça n'est bon ni
pour de très grands propriétaires et la
valeur de leur bien et l'image de leurs
biens et leur image personnelle ni pour
les habitants du du quotidien que je
soutiens complètement
c'est parti c'est un très grand pas pour
la seule nous il y avait un temps avec
l'association qui nous battons avec les
amis des chemins de soleil mais là
vraiment c'est un grand pas non moi je
suis je suis comme remo jeu comme marie
j'y crois voilà pour moi je le sais un
grand pas pour la seule aune aujourd'hui
qu'on aime franchir ce dimanche matin
c'est jour de chasse dans le loir et
cher chez xavier gassin il faut compter
à peu près une heure pour mettre toutes
les banderoles les panneaux chasse en
cours et c'est chaud c'est un convivial
on passe du temps quelque part mettre
les ponts de cé sympa se bat avec les
scénes eu chez xavier le gibier a
toujours était vivant question
d'éducation
on n'a pas été élevé comme ça
non pas du tout en fait on a eu un
voisin pendant des années qui déborde
chez nous au québec ces chiens qui
chasse est chez nous et c est là jamais
mon père eu l'idée de mettre un grillage
ou quoi que ce soit
[Musique]
m
voilà on sait pas ce qu'il ya dans le
carré aux éditions débrayages et vaud
s'est chargé sortir il y avait tant de
500 dossiers qu'a démarré quelques idées
et des faits par des posters à rien du
tout c'est toute la magie moi c'est
toute la magie vraiment la cèze ces
normes ont chargé d'émotion on sait pas
m
fin de chasse bredouille moi j'ai vu un
beau brocard à jon est une jolie bécasse
voilà c'est tout mais j'ai pas tiré le
brocart pourquoi parce que je les
trouvais un peu jeune pour le tir est
voilà à quelques dizaines de kilomètres
dans le département voisin du loiret
chez le cinéaste nicolas vanier son
dernier film l'école buissonnière est
aussi un plaidoyer contre les clôtures
la rivière monsieur la rivière est
franchissable en plein d'endroits
alors je ne veux plus qu'on entre dans
le domaine comme dans un moulin
alors le mur d'enceinte le pas en faire
le tour complet avec son mur d'enceinte
vous savez ce que ça veut dire c'est la
mort pourquoi ces gravures mur parce que
les grands animaux ça soit les sangliers
les jo et les séries ont besoin d'
espace l saison et sont un endroit puis
à une autre maïs dépasse ailleurs pour
leur nourriture mais pas seulement
j'ai grandi ici derrière des potes de
mon grand père et puis un jour comme
d'habitude parisien acheter le
territoire à côté et et nous a mis un
grillage
donc à partir de là bas ça a commencé à
changer un peu les choses comme ça a
changé tout en semaine et voilà le
cinéaste est devenu en quelques mois le
symbole de la lutte pour la libre
circulation du gibier en sologne
on aime les chasseurs il n'y a pas de
problème les chasseurs qui sont
respectueux on aime les parisiens qui
viennent et s'achète des résidences
secondaires même si c'est pour 5 ou 6
ans ou dix ans ils sont les bienvenus
parce que la chasse qu'on aime ou qu'on
aime pas c'est une réalité économique
fait vivre la sologne donc bienvenue à
ces touristes qui sont à considérer
comme des skieurs en montagne mais qu'il
respecte notre territoire
nicolas vanier est loin d'être le seul à
être enfermés par un voisin indélicat à
y voi marron sébastien camus et le
régisseur d'un territoire de chasse
appartenant à un industriel allemand
alors ici nous sommes là des voisins qui
sont enfermés avec moi ils ont ce petit
territoire qui est là et tout ça est
alors pour le reste c'est mon voisin en
grillage eur20 résultat c'est qu'on a
ici une belle prison à ciel ouvert pour
la faune de sologne qu'il est enfermé
sur un peu plus de 2000 hectares
voilà le voisin en question n'est pas
n'importe qui il foresti est un grand
patron passionné de chasse qui sait se
montrer généreux avec les autorités
locales
y a qu'à voir les relations de monsieur
forestier avec le maire dit voile marron
ou je ne dirais pas qu'ils aient une
certaine connivence mais en tout cas une
certaine compréhension pour l'année pour
l'autre monsieur forestier est aussi en
la tête d'une grosse société de location
de camions frigorifiques qui a une vue
européenne sur le marché donc il ya là
la puissance de l'argent est aussi la
puissance des des appuis politiques
il nous a donné un véhicule pour l'autre
et pas tout à fait un jour où nous
sommes pro b dans une pâte brutalement
j'ai appelé et lui dit bon bah tiens je
te donne je te confie un véhicule tu
peux le garder le temps qu'il faudra et
même le garder en permanence y compris
notre cas ce n'est pas le seul lien
entre l'industriel et le premier
magistrat dit voile marron le gendre du
maire est aussi à la tête de
l'entreprise qui a posé les grillages
chez ea forestiers sont et essai de cet
entretien de propriété donc
effectivement il pose des grillages ces
forestiers ou ailleurs d'ailleurs un
mais bon c'est son métier et ça c'est
pas un problème dans la nature de vos
relations avec justement non pas du tout
non non on ne propose pas problème en
tout cas ça pourrait peut-être l'être
certains peuvent comprendre que cet été
difficile que ce soit mais moi ça me
crée aucun aucun problème ne va pas
dormir
sébastien camus lui normal depuis
longtemps à cause des barbelés qui
encercle sa propriété mais pas seulement
son éthique de chasseurs est aussi mise
à mal par les pratiques de son voisin ce
n'est pas de la chasse c'est du
ball-trap cynégétique
c'est même pas dû battre at énergétique
c'est du ball-trap tout court c'est la
boucherie quand je vois que nous avons
territoires ouverts on faisait trois
quatre cinq pièces maximum dans l'année
c'est 50 60 80 90 cochons par chas
acheter le maximum de territoires d'une
vous défiscaliser loin monichon 2 2 vous
vendez du bois 2 3 vous vendez des
actions de chasse 2/4 le gibier tué vous
livre d'art avis on est gagnant sur tous
les tableaux
c'est dégueulasse contacté par téléphone
il forestier s'appuie sur le droit de
propriété qui permet de sans chlore et
sur la réglementation qui autorise la
chasse en parc clos toute l'année à
l'exception des oiseaux la loi est très
mal fait et je pense aussi que les
politiciens depuis une bonne trentaine
d'années encore aujourd'hui n'ont pas le
courage de dire stop
pour la simple et bonne raison c'est que
certains politiciens sont de fervents
chasseurs qui aiment aussi chasser avec
ces gens là dans ces pseudos parc
sébastien camus n'est pas le seul à être
révoltés par ces pratiques
il ya plein de chasseurs encore
aujourd'hui moi si on me met des
grillages partout si on tue la chance
mon petit mon commerce aussi dans des
petites choses comme nous on a des
bracelets ces gens là chez eux ils font
ce qu'ils veulent
disons un territoire qui leur appartient
qui est grillagé et on fait payer des
journées de chasse
c'est ça qui est en train de détruire la
chasse parce que si toute la faune est
ouverte tout le monde profite mais qui
entend la parole des chasseurs en
sologne
tout le monde connaît hubert louis
vuitton propriétaire de plusieurs
domaines et vice président de la
fédération nationale des chasseurs
c'est lui qui est en charge du dossier
sensible de l'an grillage mans grâce à
ses relations avec les grands patrons
qui chassent dans un enclos
j'ai la chance d'en connaître certains
oui c'est sûr
je ne suis déjà permis de leur dire
attention c'est pas bien c'est cette
chasse là qui sera attaqué demain c'est
celle là qui va m'empêcher mois
propriétaire à côté en espace libre qui
va m'empêcher de chasse et demain parce
qu'on va attaquer cette chasse intensive
donc j'essaye de leur faire comprendre
mais là c'est pareil chacun est chez soi
chacun est libre c'est autorisé ils me
disent ils le disent ouverts mais à
tanger le droit pourquoi je le ferai pas
[Musique]
et
l'association les amis des chemins de
sologne fondée par mary et raymond est
le porte drapeau des antilles en
grillage mans ouimet a bien fait de
démissionner là il faut qu'on rencontre
pas seulement pour savoir un peu ce
qu'on fait avec les engagements qui est
autour de celui tout ça c'est pour faire
des tableaux de chasse de plus en plus
gros et comme mon voisin il en a tué 1
sans moi je le prochain coup joueurs 220
tous les animaux comme ils sont
tellement cloîtrée dans ses aiguillages
c'est sûr que là ça fait du massacre
quand il passe à la ligne oui et sans
aucun respect ont-ils tire même délai
suite et même les petits sangliers où il
ya aucun respect aucun respect de
l'animal ils vont même pas finir un
animal qui est blessé ils sont pas
regardants à dépenser 50 cent mille
euros s'il le faut pour poser une
clôture pour poser des grilles au sol
pour men on peut pas parler ces gens là
ils sont dans un autre monde un autre
monde où toutes nos demandes d'interview
sont restés sans réponse
faire respecter la réglementation est un
combat de tous les jours sur la commune
de ville jeune on voit si le chemin
rural qui traverse la propriété de
chasse d'un couple de néerlandais
là c'est le pire exemple qui peut y
avoir une barrière une barrière avec une
grille derrière il faut savoir que ce
chemin là est un chemin qu'avait pertes
auriez ou un pour le pays s'en sert
soleil c'est un circuit équestre et donc
on peut plus on peut pas du tout
franchir cette barrière a été posée sur
sur le chemin et et voilà nous avec nos
chevaux qu'en plus du tout on peut plus
passer la c1 c'est un c'est un chemin
qui nous est privatisée finalement tout
ça au profit d'un propriétaire qui veut
pour son bien-être il veut garder les
animaux encore encore un qui emprisonne
la nature
c'est inadmissible
pourtant le maire a bien signé il y a
dix sept ans une convention afin de
laisser le libre passage des cavaliers
convention qu'il n'a jamais respecté
moi je considère que je ne suis pas dans
l'illégalité c'est tout est-ce que vous
avez conscience que c'est choquant pour
vos concitoyens pour les citoyens de ne
pas pouvoir emprunter ce chemin communal
c'est chaud colombourg une certaine
catégorie de personnes mais pour
l'ensemble des gens moi j'ai jamais eue
d'observation suggère on voit toutes
sortes de choses dans notre semaine et
c'est vrai qu'il ya beaucoup de mères
qui est baisse leurs culottes devant ces
gens là et ça ça c'est inadmissible
moi je dis là où on est mal représentée
quand même c'est honteux de voir des des
gens des mères qui est saine tout ce
qu'ils cèdent ils ont été élus par leurs
citoyens et bien on doit on doit servir
le peuple
quand on est élu on doit pas en dopant
ses cassures intérêts personnels
certains maires n'hésite pas à dire non
il suffit d'inclure dans le plan
d'occupation des sols des restrictions
sur la hauteur des clôtures a mis en
scène ce joli projet de grillage à deux
mètres est resté dans les tiroirs
effectivement c'est pas fait une bonne
relation en la personne du demandeur
mais notre objectif était de respecter
le poste et
de faire en sorte qu' on puisse mettre
un frein à l'engagement sologne
même
interdire la chasse en parc clos l'an
grillage mans et même le nourrissage
artificiel du gibier la belgique l'a
fait en wallonie et on a le bonheur de
voir qu'ici tout est ouvert
oui et donc donc vous avez su bien gérer
dans le massif de saint-hubert raymond
et marie ont rendez vous avec un des
artisans du changement de la loi
l'écologiste girard jadoul mais je pense
en fait que en 1994 le l'initiative et
est dans les mains du politique c'est
donc c'est le politique qui propose
cette nouvelle législation
et après il ya eu effectivement puisque
le politique et les c6 ambre sa mise en
application
il ya eu un tout une série de mesures de
retardement essentiellement de grands
propriétaires privés qui ont vu une
forme d'agression au sacro saint
principe de la propriété privée et qui
donc ont été en recours au conseil
d'état où donc ça a traîné la mise en
application réelle je dirais qu'elle n'a
pareil tu n as pas été effective avant
2010 probablement donc on est quand même
dans un processus de plus de 15 ans pour
pour arriver à ses fins mais mais mais
il y avait une certaine forme de lame de
fond qui rendait le qui rendait le sujet
quasiment incontournable
cette loi concerne tous les territoires
de chasse de la wallonie dont la moitié
sont privés dans le massif de
saint-hubert au lieu de la chasse en
europe
le retour à la libre circulation du
gibier a permis d'avoir des animaux en
meilleure santé parquet au moment où il
ya plus de clôture les animaux circulent
librement et donc sont capables d'aller
chercher leur nourriture où bon leur
semble donc il ya plus obligation
d'apporter de la nourriture de manière
artificielle aux animaux ça c'est une
première chose deuxième chose donc ça
entraîner des animaux en meilleure
condition physique par exemple et les
desserts ont développé des rames est
beaucoup plus important donc des bois
beaucoup plus conséquent que auparavant
et parallèlement à ça va disons que
globalement ça apporter une forme de de
bien-être supplémentaire aux animaux qui
qui vont et viennent de manière beaucoup
plus naturelle c'est-à-dire qu'au gré
des saisons ils pourront se déplacer
thierry petit et agents des forêts et
connaît le massif par coeur ils
accueillent volontiers les promeneurs
mais il a aussi le devoir de faire
appliquer la loi
on verbalise bacchantes après avoir
demandé que les gens se mettent en ordre
qui a clairement une volonté de ne pas
évoluer là on a de la chance parce
qu'elle est les parquets nous
soutiennent et justement même ils ont
fait du problème de l'engagement est un
objectif important pour que la forêt
ressemble un peu plus à un millier un
peu plus naturel et puis la chasse en
belgique c'est jugé en correctionnelle
donc c'est quand même quelque chose
d'assez important
pendant ce temps en france les choses
avancent lentement
à paris nicolas vanier a rencontré
nicolas hulot le ministre de la
transition écologique
il a pris je pense aujourd'hui la mesure
effectivement du problème et si serrar
zillow sauvage comme la sologne donner
cet exemple se retrouvent
à devenir ce qu'ils sont malheureusement
aujourd'hui des labyrinthes où les
animaux ne peuvent plus circuler
c'est absolument dramatique et ça va
poser un problème sur lequel nicolas été
particulièrement sensible qui est le
problème sanitaire
parce qu'aujourd'hui la question n'est
pas de savoir si ça va arriver c'est
quand il ya une concentration tel
d'animaux notamment de sangliers dans
certains parcs que inévitablement un cas
de tuberculose ou autres va se déclarer
va bien évidemment être communiquées à
l'extérieur parce que les maladies
travail les grillages traverse les
grillages très facilement la tuberculose
et surtout la peste porcine africaine
présente en pologne et aux portes de
l'allemagne à folle jusqu'au plus haut
niveau de l'office national de la chasse
d'autant qu'à ce jour il n'existe aucun
traitement
mais le pire scénario c'est celui là
donc voir apparaître la peste porcine
africaine donc dans un des parcs
ça veut dire que c'est une maladie qui
se propage très très vite donc on a vu
dans tous les pays concernés en europe
de l'est on a vu ddd propagation de la
maladie qui était très rapide ça veut
dire en termes d'incidence que la france
serait considérée comme atteinte par la
peste porcine africaine et on parle là
des sangliers mais c'est plutôt la
filière porcine qui serait touché et ça
contient des centaines de millions
d'euros ça veut dire qu'on ne pourrait
plus les éleveurs de porcs français ne
pourraient plus exporter de porcs à
l'étranger donc ça serait économiquement
une véritable catastrophe
il est donc urgent de se réunir de
nouveaux élus locaux associations et
fonctionnaires concernés se retrouvent
cette fois à neung-sur-beuvron au coeur
de la sologne
parce que là on n'ait vraiment
france et quand tu maillard la
catastrophe on va dire assure la
maîtrise retard proposer une perspective
solide sur le plan juridique et fiable à
l'horizon dix ou onze mois c'est déjà
une perspective extraordinaire interdire
l'importation de sangliers de pologne
dans les territoires en grillage et
modifier la réglementation concernant la
chasse en parc clos le temps presse
la grogne monte les élus locaux pensent
encore convaincre les lobbys pro
grillage prétend que je pourrai et nous
pourrions ensemble malgré notre bonne
volonté
changer le monde des attitudes et mettre
fin à tous les égoïsmes non mais je
crois j'aime trop la seule je connais
très bien les solognots je crois qu'il
existe une écrasante majorité y compris
des chasseurs y compris des agriculteurs
y compris des propriétaires pour trouver
cet équilibre entre le légitime droit de
propriété qui est un droit fondamental
et constitutionnelles que nous défendons
et le devoir éthique et juridique de
garantir une soleil ouverte et
attractive c'est possible et quand il ya
une force qui se lève il est très
compliqué même aux puissants de s'y
opposer
ça fait 20 ans qu'on en parle lui dans
quelles conditions ils veulent attaquer
le dossier là actuellement je pense que
dans 20 ans on y sera encore il faut
attaquer la loi pour arriver peut-être
une solution
connaissant certaines personnes qui
chassent dans ces lieux là la loi ne
sera pas touchée par an 20 ans de toute
façon même avec des ministres comme on a
au jour d'aujourd'hui
voilà en belgique
le changement de législation n'a
entraîné aucune modification du nombre
de chasseurs qui est resté stable
contrairement aux autres pays européens
dont la france où il est à la baisse
[Musique]
une partie minuscule du monde de la
chasse à des comportements outranciers
et et est inacceptable qui va faire en
sorte que l'énorme majorité des
chasseurs des malheureusement une
majorité silencieuse va être précipitée
dans le gouffre du non acceptation par
la société de si c'est ça la chasse
alors on la refuse
la sologne terre de marécages infestés
par le paludisme a été asséché par
napoléon iii puis colonisés par de
riches parisiens qui ont construit près
de 400 château dissimulé à l'abri des
regards mais en clôturant leur domaine
n'ont ils pas érigés en même temps des
barrières dans la tête des habitants
on a un seul homme une espèce de
soumission comme ça féodal des grands
propriétaires
c'est en train d'évoluer et moi j'ai été
extrêmement frappé j'ai fait beaucoup de
projections de l'école missionnaire dans
beaucoup de petits villages etc où il y
avait tous ces personnes qui vivent
seuls qui ne sont pas ceux qui viennent
ou quelques jours par an chassé en
sologne et lorsque j'évoquais cette
problématique des engagements c'était
des soulèvements général des salles
entières qui se levait pour applaudir et
pour dire oui faut aider nous vous
faites quelque chose effectivement très
souvent je leur ai dit mais vous savez
vous êtes responsable aussi de cette
situation parce que vous avez laissé
faire
en france le phénomène de l'an grillage
mans dépasse maintenant largement les
frontières de la sologne et s'étend
désormais à d'autres régions
mais c'est ici que l'urgence d'une
décision se fait le plus sentir note
sologne est en train de mourir
et là il faut bien savoir qu'on est
assis sur une bombe le cepod c'est
pendant deux ans et pas même dans un an
là dans les dents dans les mois qui
viennent ça peut ça peut péter il faut
le dire
il ne se passe plus une semaine sans que
de nouvelles clôtures de nouveaux
barbelés fleurissent le long des routes
de sologne réduisant un peu plus serbie
chez sanglier à l'état d'animaux
domestiques
un enfermement qui conduit à poser le
problème éthique et morale d'une chasse
où plus rien n'est respecté et où même
le mot de chasse a perdu son sens
[Musique]